hello everybody my name is Marc Lauren
and continued down the strange road of
games I've been playing with a lot of
unicorns in them
hmm right I am now playing clop and if
you know what QWOP is then you'll know
that clop is made by the same guy that
made clop clop is about a unicorn a
pretty prancing unicorn that you use the
lk j h ki the H&K move the front leg L&J
move the back leg o as a key to
destruction either done or not but ah my
god
you got to move it in a rhythmic fashion
so that you don't dhak dhak dhak die oh
I gave it a try once before to just get
my bearings in Oh No steadily wonder I
may not be prancing but I'm a walk oh no
yeah yeah technique ha ha ha ha
ah shut up
oh yeah okay so if we just go steadily
along we'll make it if we're not in a
rush we'll get there in no time
maybe other doesn't look like my horse
is on any sort of psycho huh oh my god
oh we made it
I did oh if I can get my cleft hoof into
that almost Erick top of the hill with
my patented front part oh no oh no my
legs no my legs my leg my leg Oh lame
hahahaha lame horse mode unlocked what
da now I just have front legs I think
that means I broke my back legs haha but
I'm making it differently
I'm gonna get your pretty lady oh you
gonna tell me already this game is kind
of rich
my back legs do not work out but I'm
gonna make it done good food good ooh
Babaloo this box is here to war anybody
who tries to cheat and hold it because
your front legs
this is where my majestic adventure ends
sadly oh my legs are they working relax
oh they're working oh my oh okay
that is where my majestic and adventure
ends but it's where yours just begins
yes you too can feel the thrill that is
claw also quoi if you'd like so late in
the description thank you guys so much
for watching click the annotation for
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you
I got something
your face
we don't have those plates now
Oh